what do you got there my wife wants to
see ID oh let me see there you say hi to
your friend here there you are look at
you obviously doesn't she look like a
drug dealers wife right there yeah she
looks like she married to Pablo Escobar
yes he looks like she just got off the
plane from Medellin Allari when you have
a husband like Alec Baldwin everyone
wants him everyone wants a piece of him
everyone's trying to get you know near
him how do you keep or trying to
handcuff it right how do you get or
handcuff him depending on the day how do
you keep the romance alive when you're
when you're on a date with Alec and he
takes you home and he's making love to
you do you say to yourself oh my god I'm
with Alec Baldwin one of our greatest
actors one of the great leading man days
what are you thinking during check no no
when you were having sex she's thinking
we better hurry I know the baby
screaming in the other room and he and
he delivers the goods doesn't he yes and
and by the way I follow you on Instagram
why are there no more yoga shots that's
my favorite when you do yoga I gotta be
like Woody Allen when we had dinner with
woody did he say I'll tell you that
story he's sitting there we're having
dinner in Rome and he goes so were you
you do yoga right you can really bend
yourself into all of those positions
right he like it was elated he was high
you love that right Alec I mean that is
it who would imagine that one day you'd
be married a woman he is so she gets hit
on all day long is that true
Pablo Escobar's wife gets hit on all day
long look at look at her
what do you mean like when you're away
from but to you